Hello everyone and welcome back to Web Security.
In this video I'm going to be talking to you all about the Structured Query Language, commonly
referred to as SQL.
So SQL, Structured Query Language, is a very commonly used language for manipulating and
accessing and querying data.
So SQL is a language in and of itself, of course, you know, Structured Query Language.
It is a language and if you want to understand how web applications work, particularly those
that use Structured Query Language, which is again very common for manipulating and
accessing data, we need to understand what it is that the Structured Query Language is.
So I'm going to be talking to you all about the basics of Structured Query Language, SQL.
So the first operation that is very important and good to know about is the create table
operation.
So SQL operates off of a paradigm of you have these databases and within those databases
you have tables and then within those tables you have rows and you have columns.
So you can kind of think of something like some sort of spreadsheet application, right?
You can have a bunch of pages in your spreadsheet application and you have rows and columns
with holding data.
So the first thing we want to be able to do is we want to be able to create a table that's
going to store data.
So in order to do that we're going to use the create table operation and we're going
to specify some table name as well as some column names and potentially column attributes.
So for example, if we want to create some users table, we run the create table users
and then we're specifying username and password as two of the columns within that.
And in doing so we've suddenly birthed a new table within our database called users and
it's ready to have a bunch of users with a username and password.
So right now we've just got an empty table with users, username and password are the
attributes, the columns of a particular user which is some row within that users table.
So now if you want to add some data to that table, we want to use the insert into function
which is we can insert into some table name values and then specify the values you want
to insert in, in order of those columns.
So for example, if we want to insert the admin admin user, we can run insert into users values
admin admin.
Note the double quotes here or you could use single quotes but we are inserting the string
values into our table and suddenly we have a concept of a user, some data backing a user
concept where we have one of them which is an admin whose username is admin and whose
password is admin as well.
And if we want to continue on to insert more data into this table, right every, every time
we perform one of these operations, we're inserting another row into the table.
Now we have Connor password 123 and finally we add Canac with Hunter2 as a password.
So we've got this table set up with some data with three users in it, each with a unique
username and password and you know you could imagine now we're ready to start having a
web application, right?
You can imagine some web application had a create user page and when you went to create
that user, well now we need to run this operation of inserting that user into our database.
Our database stores data, right?
It stores all the data that's going to be critical for this web application.
Now if we want to start querying that data, we're going to use the select operation.
So we can select some number of columns from some table name where there can be some conditions
on what kind of rows you want to select from that, what kind of query you want to perform
in order to determine what you want to select.
So for example in the base case, we can select username, password from users and that's just
going to return all of the usernames and passwords of the table, right?
We're going to get all these rows with different columns within those rows and we can access
it, we can know all of the usernames and passwords of all of the users within our database.
On the other hand, we might just select the users.
You can imagine a web application, you might want to know who all the users are in my web
application.
So we're going to query for all of the usernames within the web application, within the database
and to do so we just select username from users and suddenly we have all of the usernames
within our users table.
You can also, if you don't want to specify particular columns you want to select, if
you just want to select them all, you can use this star token and the star token just
means hey give me all of the columns, give me all of the attributes of all of the users
now.
Because again we haven't specified a condition yet, we're just selecting everything from
all of the users.
So we're going to get all of the usernames and passwords.
Now we might also do select star from users where username equals admin.
So we might want to find information about some particular user whose, in this case,
username is admin.
So we query, hey give me everything about the user, the users in this case, whose username
is admin.
Well it turns out there's one user whose username is admin and the result contains the information
about them.
Alternatively, you might imagine some login operation, right?
Hey give me all of the users whose username is admin and whose password is password.
Well it turns out as we kind of look to the left, right, the admin user has a username
of admin and a password of admin so no rows are returned.
There's no users who have a username of admin and password of password.
So nothing comes back.
It's an empty result.
Of course, if we log in correctly, if we supply a username of admin and a password of admin,
then sure enough we find that user whose username is admin and whose password is admin.
Hopefully it's clear how you can imagine using this language with this data to build up a
web application with users and have this login operation, right?
Your login operation is going to look something like this.
Okay.
Now if you want to be able to add data and query data, you probably also want to be able
to delete data.
So we have this delete from table name where conditions and this allows us to conditionally
start deleting data.
So for example, delete from users where username equals Canac.
So we just deleted the Canac user.
They're no longer going to exist in the database.
The data for them if we perform a further query, it's nothing that's going to come up.
We've deleted that row.
We've deleted that user.
Alternatively, rather than just inserting and deleting data and querying it, you might
also want to update data.
So we have update table name set some set of assignments where conditions.
So in this case, we are changing a password.
You can imagine an operation where you might want a user to be able to change their password.
So we say update users, set password to password 456 where username equals Connor.
And suddenly Connor's password is no longer password 123.
It is password 456.
We just performed a password update operation in the kind of more specific to a user management
web application.
You can imagine this operation being important.
We also have the capability of unioning two queries together when we select data, select
bits of data.
Maybe you select from one table and select from another table.
You might want to union that together.
In this case, I'm going to show you, you know, you might, I don't know what operation this
would correspond into where you'd want to do this, but you can perform this operation.
You might select username from users and then union that in with select password from users.
And suddenly you're just going to end up with a bunch of rows with just one column.
So this isn't two columns anymore.
It's just one column.
And we have the usernames and the passwords in this column.
You're going to notice here that it's being labeled as usernames, even though the right
hand is kind of passwords.
Now, traditionally, when that result comes back, it's just going to all get merged into
the first selections attribute names.
So that first selection is selecting for usernames, which means that first columns attribute name,
that first columns name is going to be username.
And that's just going to carry on.
It's just going to use that as the default label for that column.
Not super important necessarily, but that's kind of what's going on there, why we're calling
it all usernames.
Now we also have this concept of a schema table, which isn't an operation in and of
itself, but it turns out you have this default table that in this case, we're looking specifically
at SQLite, though there's also like MySQL and Postgres and all these other database
management systems that have slightly different dialects to SQL.
In this case, we're looking at SQLite, which is kind of considered the simple one, the
simplest one.
It's really just backed by a file on your file system.
It's a very simple database solution here.
And it has this concept of a schema table that is called SQLite underscore master.
And SQLite underscore master has a whole bunch of rows and columns.
And one of those columns is named table underscore name or tbl underscore name.
And if you wanted to query all of the names of all the tables, an operation you could
do is to actually query that SQLite master table, select the table names from that, and
you're going to get all of the table names.
This is kind of a meta operation that might be useful depending on if you need these kind
of meta operations to start performing queries on the database at like a meta level that
all of the popular database management systems, whether it's SQLite, MySQL, Postgres, et cetera,
all have this sort of schema table.
All have something similar.
It's not going to look exactly the same, but have some sort of table that's managing data
about the database that can be useful in some circumstances.
And I figured I would mention it here.
Now finally, if we kind of want to come full circle, you might want to just completely
get rid of a table.
You might want to drop a table.
So the drop table operation just entirely drops that table from existence.
It no longer exists.
And by performing the drop table operation, it's gone, right?
We run that operation, drop table users, and suddenly the users table is just gone from
existence.